[Aplausos]
quería empezar mi charla pidiéndoles que
hagamos algo juntas
pongamos la espalda recta
levantemos los brazos en forma de l
tenemos los puños
y pongámonos los en la cintura
y ahora sonriamos mucho como si fuera la
primera vez que lo hiciéramos y la
última también
los sentidos
acabamos de liberar serotonina
endorfinas y dopamina le acabamos de
enviar la orden a nuestro cerebro de que
somos personas poderosas
y no lo digo yo esto es palabra de amy
cádiz
la psicóloga que es experta en lenguaje
corporal y habla de como el lenguaje
corporal nos dice quiénes somos
otra cosa que nos habla de quiénes somos
las preguntas que hacemos
porque la luna nos persigue
si me columpio demasiado fuerte
este va a romper el asiento
si le doy este trozo de pan a mi hermano
se va a morir
estas son algunas de las preguntas que
yo hacía constantemente de pequeña
preguntas que en realidad me hicieron
ganarme el apodo de burrito de shrek
lo que es una manera cariñosa de decir
hija mía no caigas ni debajo del agua
eso me hizo darme cuenta que la
curiosidad en realidad es una semilla y
que el burrito de rey que era curioso
profundamente curioso
la curiosidad es una semilla que si se
adoba y se cuida con la determinación
necesaria se convierte en un árbol
robusto y maravilloso la curiosidad es
el paso previo a florecer es el inicio
de todo
si hablamos de curiosidad hablamos
también de irons words
se le conoce con el apodo de el hijo de
internet
para que con un pequeño dato nos podamos
dar cuenta de cómo revolucionó el
ciberespacio tan solo deciros que con 12
años creo de info es un portal web en el
que se podía introducir información y
editarla con tan sólo unos clics algo
así como wikipedia antes de que
wikipedia existiera
su madre decía de él que era
inmensamente curioso que su curiosidad
no tenía fin
cuando eran murió tim berners-lee el
creador de la world wide web dijo que el
mundo había perdido un mentor a un sabio
loco
pero por otro lado en su momento dijo
que lo que en realidad siempre se
identifica como inteligencia no es nada
más que curiosidad
y es que la curiosidad es una
oportunidad para tomar las riendas de
nuestro aprendizaje nos permite decidir
el qué
y el cómo lo queremos aprender
tu país tu familia
tu pasado y tu presente e incluso tu
universidad
nada de eso le importa tu curiosidad
la curiosidad sólo necesita que tú seas
el motor
iron shorts por ejemplo estudio en
stanford un año al siguiente lo dejo
para fundar la red social media
y esque
quien no ha tenido en su clase una
persona que parece que lo sabe todo es
increíble pero no necesariamente sea esa
persona la que saque las mejores notas o
por ejemplo puedo hablar de una
experiencia personal y vice piano
durante cinco años y creo que si ahora
tuviera que volverlo a tocar en realidad
tendría que empezar de cero en cambio mi
hermano con unos tutoriales de youtube y
con una curiosidad infinita en pocas
semanas estaba tocando una pieza de
mozart
entonces
porque tenemos muy claro que la
curiosidad es la clave
tenemos muy claro que aprender por
aprender no vale la pena que es aprender
por curiosidad desbordante cómo lo
hacemos
atreviéndonos
siendo un poquito más el burrito de rec
no hay un método exacto
pero y sant pau
es una profesora que creo que designó
cuatro indicadores de la curiosidad
que podríamos decirlo de manera más
sencilla como cuatro pasos para ser
curiosa
el primero reaccionar reaccionar de
manera positiva y observadora a todos
los estímulos de nuestro entorno la
curiosidad es también un antídoto del
prejuicio
el segundo
desear desear saber más cosas sobre lo
que vemos sobre lo que leemos sobre los
estímulos que recibimos buscar buscar
más experiencias nuevas
y el último resistir persistir en esta
búsqueda en buscar más sobre la
información sobre nuestros estímulos
hay un momento un momento en nuestras
vidas que generalmente se da cuando
estamos en clase en el que dejamos de
levantar la mano o dejamos de preguntar
un poco por el miedo al qué dirán
a equivocarnos hacer un error
incluso a molestar al profesor
ahí es donde la curiosidad muere y ese
es el momento que tenemos que intentar
revertir
ser curioso
y poder ir un paso más lejos es por eso
que es la clave para poder aprender
así que cuando no sepamos cómo hacerlo
explotemos nuestra curiosidad
hacemos niños un poquito más burrito de
rec
y para quitarnos todos los miedos
hagámoslo con una sonrisa y con una pose
de poder de película así nada puede
salir mal gracias
[Aplausos]